I'm standing outside the bank of new
zealand at Cenotaph corner in regular we
are looking at a initiative of the
regular community board now the regular
Ashley community board to beautify the
town centre as a result of the
earthquakes and the street upgrades that
have gone on one of my favorite pictures
here is one of the market day in 1910
what appeals to me about that is all the
gigs stacked up and those of you that
understand farming in those days the
farmers would go off to the market have
a successful sale have a few noggin and
my mind just boggles as they try and
untangle that web of gigs at the end of
the day this is another picture that I
find really interesting this is the
junction hotel Natalie known as Robbie's
it was originally damaged in the
nineteen twenty two earthquakes and that
lost the upper part of the parapet it
was further damage in the 2010-11
earthquakes but it has been saved the
front has been saved in the rest of the
building demolished so it's an important
part of the regular history this picture
is of worth elephant from 1951 taken as
though braiding down the high street on
their way to Dudley park well I think
it's important about this picture is
that something will never ever see in
ring your again as circus animals are
really a thing of the past I hope you
found these pictures interesting they
depict much of the history of regular if
you'd like to see more of them they can
be seen at the regular Museum in good
Street
[Music]